- I heard that you,
speaking of people just coming up to you,
I heard that one time you
were in an airport, was it?
(Jay laughing)
And a lady came up and slapped you.
- [Jay] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] And, what?
- She reached back to, like,
eighth grade and she was, like,
"Ramone, I got something for you."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(Jay growling)
- Your name was not Ramone.
(Jay and Kelly laughing)
- No.
- Lies.
- Yeah, so I was at the
airport and I was going to get,
I was going to, like, get
some Advil or something from,
like, one of those little turnstiles and,
like, the magazine store.
And there was a woman standing
on the other side of it,
and before I turn it, I'm like, "Hey."
And it's going to, like,
bump into her if I turn it.
So, I'm like, "Hey, excuse
me, I just wanna turn this."
She turns around and looks at
me, and her eyes, literally,
were like, this big and she reached back,
and it was so far, that I
could have probably dodged it.
(audience member laughing)
- It was like slow-mo.
- It was like, but it was also,
I couldn't believe what was happening,
and literally she, I mean,
you could hear her hand cut
through the wind, this...
(Jay imitating wind and slapping)
(hand slaps)
And like, slap across my face.
- Which is not okay.
- [Jay] At all.
(audience laughing)
- No.
- But she immediately went
to like, Macaulay Culkin,
and she was like, "Oh my god!"
Look, she started
screaming and she's like,
"I'm so sorry, I didn't mean to do that,
you remind me of my
ex-boyfriend, like he, we,
(audience laughing)
and you're like, Lawrence
is just like him.
And like, seeing you was seeing
him, and like I'm just..."
And literally, it was this crazy moment.
- Like ma'am.
That's not okay!
(audience laughing)
Well what am I supposed to say?
- [Kelly] That.
- Lawrence is triggering,
you know, like...
- No. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- What am I supposed to say?
- But that's a character.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- But for some people,
listen I always say...
- Like if somebody walked up and was like,
"I hated 'Since You've Been Gone'."
Like,
(Jay and audience laughing)
like that's your problem ma'am, like what?
- That's true.
- Yeah, that's weird. That's definitely...
- But I wasn't gonna call
airport police on her.
- Not acceptable.
That's 'cause you're nice.
(Jay and audience laughing)